si has estado viendo nuestros vídeos ya
sabes que existen muchos escenarios
donde las personas acercan a nosotros en
la calle para hacernos preguntas
matemáticas y supongo que este vídeo no
será diferente así que vamos a decir que
alguien va caminando en la misma calle
que tú se acerca a ti y te pregunta
deprisa amigo cómo puede simplificar la
división de x cuadrada más 5 x más 8 / x
+ 2 cuál es el resultado de dividir x
cuadrada más 5 x más 8 / x + 2 pausa el
vídeo e intenta resolverlo
bueno hay dos formas de resolver esta
división la primera es intentar
factorizar el numerador y ver si existe
un factor común o podemos intentar usar
una división algebraica larga primero
intentemos factorizar el numerador y
realmente esperamos que x + 2 sea uno de
los factores así que pensemos en dos
números que al sumarse resulten en cinco
y que al multiplicarse resulten en ocho
y de manera ideal 2 es uno de ellos así
que vamos a pensarlo un poco
2 y 3 suman 5 para multiplicar se dan 6
18 no no se me ocurre nada más aún así
creo que tuvimos un progreso qué tal si
escribimos esto como x cuadrada más 5x y
queremos un 6 ya que esto sería
divisible entre x más 2
así que escribiré más 6 pero como en un
inicio tenemos 18 sumaré + 2 adicional
justo aquí todo esto lo estamos
dividiendo entre x bastos ahora podemos
reescribir toda la primera parte que
estoy atrapando en color rojo como x 2 x
x + 3 y no olvidemos que al final hay
uno más dos en el numerador todo esto
dividido entre x más 2 lo puede escribir
como la primera parte entre x + 2 y la
segunda parte entre x + 2 lo único que
hice fue decide si tengo una cosa más
otra cosa
entre x + 2 es lo mismo que la primera
la cosa entre x2 más la segunda cosa
entre x2 y ahora podemos ver que esta
primera parte mientras x no sea igual a
menos 2 ya que eso cambiaría el dominio
entonces tenemos que estos dos se
cancelan podemos decir que estamos
dividiendo el numerador y el denominador
por x + 2 entonces podemos decir que
esto es igual a x + 3 e incluso podemos
quitar el paréntesis si queremos más 2
entre x + 2 por último no olvidemos
poner la restricción para el dominio
esto es para toda x distinta a menos 2
en esta situación tenemos un residuo las
personas suelen llamarle altos como el
residuo dividimos tanto como pudimos y
aún así queda nuestro residuo dividido
entre x + 2 entonces decimos que este 2
es justo nuestro residuo
parece que no fuera tan difícil y sí muy
directo pero vamos a ver que en este
caso la división larga es aún más
directa pausa el vídeo e intenta una vez
más recuerda de que se trata de la
división algebraica larga
bueno x2 va a dividir a x cuadrada 5 x +
8 bien primero pensamos en los términos
con grado mayor x y x cuadrada x cabe x
veces en x cuadrada lo ponemos en la
columna de primer grado y multiplicamos
x por dos es 2 x x x x es x cuadrada
préstamos estás de x cuadrada más 5 me
queda 5 x 2 x es 3x y x cuadrada - x
cuadrada se cancelan son sólo 0 bajamos
ahora el 8 y pensamos de nuevo en los
términos de grado mayor x cabe en 3 x 3
veces entonces ponemos un 3 en la
columna de términos constantes o de
grado 0 ok
+ 3 y dice 3 por 12 6 y 3 por x es 3x
restemos estos dos se cancelan y nos
quedamos con 8 menos
es lo que es de hecho igual a 2
podemos decir oye realmente no sabemos
cómo dividir dos entre x más 2 para una
ex arbitraria por lo tanto esto será
igual a x + 3 con un residuo de 2
una vez más si tú quieres escribir la
expresión original y quieres que sea
completamente igual e incluir el dominio
entonces tendrás que poner esta
restricción en el dominio justo de esta
manera